well so so going back to the point about
the escalation and conflict and all this
stuff
because we kind of deviated when i
started talking about trump's airplane
full of people
hey it's a good point what do you
think's going to happen in the election
we got the mail-in voting problem we got
no one no one knows who's going to win
there have been a bunch of scenarios
proposed
by by high profile individuals on the
left the founder of msnbc said
he thinks that the the house will give
it to trump
even though biden wins essentially and
that it's going to lead to chaos
so this is a real emotional switch right
here this is
something that i'm not a psychic so
please nobody in november clip this up
to
try to discredit me but this is my real
raw
feelings i think the energy the momentum
and the people are behind donald trump
and i think it's evident
i mean it was do do you know do you want
to know something i was at the
acceptance speech for biden
and i have a video that went viral
of his own there was only one supporter
i saw that one guy
yeah he goes i'm the only guy here and
everyone else was trump supporters
in his own home city of wilmington
delaware
he couldn't garner support and the rest
of the people were screaming at trump
supporters for not wearing masks outside
i i was so shocked that i know if this
was a fair election
donald trump would win in a landslide
and not because
you love him or hate him it's just very
evident by what's going on
take a look at this image sean parnell
says
joe biden emerged from his basement and
flew to pittsburgh pennsylvania on a
private jet to speak to six
people and take no questions from the
press
outside he drew a crowd of almost 100
people way to go joe legit
home state enthusiasm it's his home
state this makes me sad
well it's it's arguably his homestead i
know he's you know joe biden's delaware
for the most part but yeah his pa is
supposed to be a state look at this
photo
this this this this shocked me to my
core i
wept when i saw this photo elijah i said
no joe
literal tears i'm kidding joke but this
is
it's it's insane did you see you know
what i noticed is that when he's doing
interviews with uh kamala kamala how do
you say kamala
kamala kamala kamala can't feel half of
it you're racist
you say you're you're racist if you say
it wrong by the way yeah kamala can't
fill half a high school gym that's a
true story
i went to her rally she couldn't feel
half a high school gym i'm telling you
pep rallies
could fill more people than that but she
uh
they were like in these interviews
they're like 30 feet apart
her and joe it makes me wonder it sounds
weird
are they taped at different times are
they done with a split to
allow timing because i know how things
work i work in editing i'm going
the only way i could think that things
are cut like this other than pure
insanity
and be beyond beyond because if you want
about security it's like trump is more
hated than joe
and trump doesn't have this kind of
level of of distance
why is it like that you see this video
where where trump signing autographs
he's like patting people on the back and
shaking hands like he doesn't he's just
he's
a boss he didn't care he's a boss he
drinks he drinks coke and he
eats big macs what a cool guy you know
why he does that though right because he
likes good
food because he he believes that
fast food chains have national standards
and are more
are less likely to get you sick and that
he doesn't
like he doesn't trust a random
individual restaurant because he doesn't
know what their standards are
he knows the fast food restaurants have
nationalized he's the only guy who eats
drunk food and doesn't drink
right exactly what a legend he's like
he's like look guys i'm gonna be like a
drunk guy at 2 a.m
but completely sober and owning the
entire uh entire far left
with just one bite and remember he he he
tipped everybody off with
buying mcdonald's for that team yeah
that's so weird why would they get mad
at that
the team apparently loved it those guys
eat like burgers stale fungus
like you know what i mean like like
that's good for them
all right i want to show you one more
thing before we go to super chats though
have you seen lebron james's uh
new shirt oh can you read that for me
ah i wish i didn't have to but it says
vote or die huh lebron james man
this guy i'm sorry he's not smart
you know like his comments on china
american dream man just get rich not be
smart
and live in the best country in the
world one of the best basketball players
but i'm saying you don't have to be
smart you just go around and throw
around a little ball
hang out make giant brand deals and then
just talk crud on your whole country
that got you there but there there are
there are nba players who are standing
up for this country
and you know are legit and i'm not
saying they're necessarily smart do they
get air time though that's the question
well you saw that dude who tore his acl
what was that guy's name i don't pay
attention i don't remember
i don't remember i should though because
that dude he stood up for the flag and
everything
but anyway look i'm not i'm not i don't
really care that much about lebron i'm
trying to rag on him everything like
that but
he wore this shirt said vote or die i'd
like to show you south park
this is the south part at least we know
that unless it was comedy central
they're not going to rip you because
these guys still have a sense of humor
this is a picture from south park right
here it's puff daddy he's holding up a
shirt says voter die we can't show the
video huh
no no no copyright yeah and they're all
swearing right so yes and he's chasing
around stan and they're like shooting at
him and so this is what we were watching
earlier
yeah oh hilarious i didn't even know the
connection i was like why are you
watching
it was so weird i like south park
actually it's kind of weird because i'm
a christian
and you know my mom my mom uh you know
rest in peace she she used to because
she was like my dad's a pastor
my mom's a pastor's wife so she would
like hate she used to hate south park
because
it was like you know it was just a lot
of like private jokes and things it
really was it used to be like a show
that didn't know what it was there for
and jew jokes and things
that are just crass and the average
person doesn't like and it's kind of
distasteful edgy whatever but kids liked
it
it's weird how they've become like the
most honest political
like i guess commentary show and it's a
paper cartoon
these guys have they're not even
conservatives or anything
have seen through the bs almost better
than anyone and what a statement in 2020
that like a guy named tim poole who's
not with a network who funds himself and
is not getting back in money from some
country
is having one of the most powerful
voices and even more slap in the face
is not just a guy on youtube running
more successful business and getting
more viewers than a network by the way
it's like i mean it really is true i
mean you get millions and millions and
millions and millions of dollars
in these terrible shows and you're
getting a better viewership live
viewership
than all these organizations non-profits
et cetera but then it's like a step
further it's like well maybe tim pool's
just this guy in a beanie and he knows
something but it's like
what if we just cut up some paper and
manipulate it on our computer and it
tells a truer story
than multi-million dollar broadcast
networks i mean
south park's establishment though like
they they it doesn't matter if it's
establishment it's just like look at the
technology behind it
it's improved it's like they actually
have animation programs now sure but if
you watch if you watch the way they put
the show together
the the creators even say sometimes
they're they're rendering it minutes
before it airs yeah they just don't care
yeah they do it in real time i i think i
haven't watched any of the later
episodes but it's hilarious just to see
that these
shows like south park and the simpsons
have predicted so much you know but it's
it's so honest and that's what's gonna
say about the show like she used to not
like it but then
she warmed up to it my mom not she
wouldn't watch it by the way my mom if
people that know her she had a
cult following too she had not watched
south park but she understood when i'd
show her you know parts about it that it
became
the humor stopped being oh i gotta make
a racist joke or i gotta make this kind
of joke it was like
society is the joke let's just look at
society
and look at how crazy it is and no
longer humor is not cr it's not edgy
because it's crass or edgy because it's
discriminatory
it's just edgy because real life is just
a freaking clown show
yep you know you know do you know the
who who's the guy who wrote the thing uh
was it kafka no i don't think what about
the clown
and this and the fire that i think was
i think it was who was that girtay
no look it up he's googly yeah i will
but i was i don't think it's i'm trying
to get some credit for myself here
because yeah
i believe you were incorrect tonight no
okay you're wrong
all right all right it's like it's like
if i hear him like that's the guy do you
know the story about the clown
i'm talking about biden still or who are
we talking about it's the it's the clown
star man okay all right it's a long
story
clown comes out on stage because there's
a fire breaking out backstage and he
starts screaming everyone run there's a
fire they'll start laughing
he says no no seriously seriously the
fire you guys get out and they'll start
laughing even harder
and harder and then like i don't know i
was wrong and i yeah who is it
geez i'm just doing great over here
tonight
turkey guy can you can you read the
story okay so a fire broke out backstage
in a theater the clown came
out to warn the public they thought it
was a great joke and applauded
he repeated it the acclaim was even
greater i think that's just how the
world will come to an end
to general applause from wits who
believe it's a joke
there it is wow it's a it's listen man
lebron james is wearing a voter die
shirt
it's literally a joke from south park
can i just can i just say i think we i
think in 2016 the sweet meteor of death
actually came and wiped us all out and
we all
went to purgatory together so this was
this was before this video on south park
was made before
yeah yeah like years ago man oh my
you know right that's the point lebron
james
unironically wore a shirt where they
were making fun of the idea
a decade ago like i don't even know this
episode's from the stop the youtube
videos from 2014.
lebron's actually wearing vote or die
what
dude you know what man i tell you what
i don't i don't take it to a dark place
you know i have to talk about scary
things riots man people are getting
killed it's getting crazier and crazier
and i laugh
oh you know what i do listen this is the
way you got to view the world
you wake up in the morning you might
find that uh
things are bad but if you always take it
to a dark place you'll never get ahead
you got to learn to laugh at the
craziness
and you got to learn to you you got to
learn to respect the gifts you are given
i'll tell you what there's a lesson
people got to learn
you right now you've got you've got it
made you're one of the richest people in
the world
you know that americans this is a great
country
if you is what i tell people if you were
buck naked in the middle of the woods
alone that's you at zero if you're buck
nagging in the middle of the woods and
you got a pointy stick
you got something you're doing better if
you're bug naked in the middle of the
woods and you know you got to cut and
you're bleeding now you're negative
it's really really hard for me to view
anything as necessarily detrimental to
me
like if i got that's why i'm always like
if they banned me i'm not going to cry
about it i'm just going to be like oh
i guess there it is i got my health i
got my skateboard
i got friends that's good good cats a
good life you know and i and i think
that i i
i want to point this out there's a
really funny statement that a friend and
i we were just laughing together you
know you just have those good times
have some beers hanging out whatever
chilling maybe it's an iced tea you
prefer
whatever and you know i was i was joking
i was going
all these people want you to be this or
that and they you know they rag on you
why don't you say this why aren't you
like that while you're just trying to be
you and i go you know
it's like we were talking there's nobody
out there that is talking
crud that is a hater that is just
completely trying to tear you down
that has a life that i envy it's like
every night it's like ultimately
my wife is not just my wife she's my
best friend she's incredible she she
really and it's not just saying that
it's like
she's so much fun to hang out with she's
my priority we
are she good at video games um she's
good at animal crossing oh okay
that counts all right i'll accept it
she's a pretty good island i'm not gonna
lie
but i was gonna say uh you know is that
is that we're there we hang out
every every day when i come back from
these rights i come home i have
a woman who loves me i have a dwarf
hamster who couldn't give a crap if i
died tonight
but i feed him anyways his name is gus
he's morbidly obese and he and he and he
might be racist
but that racism yeah but i but i will
say this that you know but it's like i
have a great place we're thinking about
having some kids
it's like there's no weird far-left
writing or anything that can take away
the fact that me and my wife love each
other
that we have a good life and you know
what we've been poor before
we could be poor again she grew up in
africa with nothing i grew up
you know in near poverty with a dad who
tried to start a church we we grew up
near gangs and everything i didn't know
i live in a poor neighborhood of la
which people don't know that l.a can be
very ghetto actually
it can be very poor even it's america it
can get very very dangerous and bad
and we've come from nothing and we've
had nothing together
and ultimately what makes us happy and
what brings us together is just
the fact that we have a good outlook on
life that we love god we love each other
and we live to protect this country from
people who want to destroy it
and it's like and in the end you can
shoot me with rubber bullets dhs
department of homeland security i'm just
getting over an injury they broke my
shin in portland
whoa really yeah they shot point blank
with a canister rocket like a
gas propelled cancer it split open my
shin and cracked my shin
and i fell to the ground it was really
bad and i was off the field for a few
weeks
but i'm back and i've been positive
through it all gotta wear armor bro
all right i didn't know shin guards were
necessary at riots
i mean if you're consistently doing
conflict then
the number one rule is never stand in
between the police and
the writers well unfortunately there's
portland is hard to do that right right
but i'm just saying
doing it in favelas in brazil well i'm
not one day i'll get to your level
oh no i'm i'm i'm i'm out of that i just
i just sit in my my i'm a tim pond not a
tim pool
one day one day my pond will widen into
a pool there you go
i just sit in my room and talk and talk
you know complain on the internet about
my feelings now
it became too dangerous they started i
started getting harassed starting death
threats and they recognized
me and then you reached a certain
threshold and i think you might run into
that too
i don't think it's safe now but you know
antifa treats me pretty fairly now after
they've given me two concussions
actually
i've been i got hit in the head with
like brass knuckle type things just back
in january they
i have a dent in my skull yeah they just
came up they try to rob my
my producer of his camera and then they
punched me in the back of the head
and luckily i was wearing a bit of a
bump cap but they still hit and put a
little dent in the back cracked open my
skull
i've been in conflict with them but most
recently i've been straight up telling
them
i'm past the point of taking crap
anymore just in case you're watching
i will never attack anyone i'm a
completely defensive person
but if my life is in danger i am now
fully capable without
hinting on what that means i am fully
capable and surrounded by people to
defend it and i and i do not operate out
of a place of of
a vulnerability anymore and i and they
know that and they put alerts out and
i'm telling you if you're part of antifa
if you're around these people
elijah schafer is not somebody you want
to mess around with because even if you
somehow took me out
you would be taken out very shortly
after because of the people i'm
surrounded with so that's just a
statement
don't start fights do not start fighting
don't break the law do not start fights
with me i
i anybody don't break the law but me
particularly don't try it
yeah don't do it that's fair you know at
a certain point to be
most effective you can see that there
are some people who just can't go on the
ground anymore
because they get targeted and it was
happening to me and i was like i don't
want to be on the ground
being the story with people running up
to me and that's what was happening but
i'm going to covert now
yeah sometimes i spend 250 bucks on a
trip
changing outfits and buying new clothes
and sometimes in a day i'll change three
times
while covering things wow multiple armor
colors covert
shirts i mean i was going to i was going
to stands a black lives matter stand
buying clothing off the street just to
change while i was at a riot i
just throw clothes in the trash while
i'm out and buy stuff at stores
and i just change my appearance i have
lots of glasses et cetera and that's
what it's come down to if you don't
invest heavily in
in different appearances they'll target
you
you've got to look people know how you
look yeah but when i would go out
you know i would wear relatively
different things but
yeah definitely i wear the same clothes
it's a war game now it's a war game
i mean we i i i you have to treat it
like you're a war reporter
and i know and i don't know i'm not
fluffy conflict is conflict bro that's
what i'm saying it's like i'm not like
going i don't walk out like
like wearing like john wick like i'm
gonna come out it's just like you
realize
that it's not just like the press aren't
safe anybody who's exposing the truth by
name you know they want to kill your
guest
is he coming to moderate dreams yeah
yeah they want to they literally are
trying to kill him
of course like like murder this i've had
them post pictures of my mom
i but it doesn't make sense cause it's
like this is a guy just filming stuff
doesn't well they don't want the truth
getting out i hate these people they
want to be able to propagandize and
destroy
with impunity and journalism hurts that
so journalists are big companies they
don't want to take the risk one of these
guys get paid 30 40 grand at some of
these garbage companies and they're like
you want me to insult these guys i'll
show up to my house
and they agree with them too a lot most
of them do i'd say that's not fair
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you